Act now.
BRIAN:  DO YOU BELIEVE THESE
PICTURES?
UNBELIEVABLE, TWO SIBLINGS JUST
FIVE AND SIX YEARS OLD SAVED BY
BORDER AGENTS ALL BY THEMSELVES.
THE LATEST IN THE SURGE OF MINOR
S ABANDONED AT THE BORDER.
THE RESCUE COMES AS
APPREHENSIONS EXPLODE TO
RECORD LEVELS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT TURN
THEMSELVES IN BUT ACCORDING TO
NANCY PELOSI, JOE BIDEN’S
POLICIES ARE REALLY WORKING WELL
>> THE FACT IS IS THAT WE’RE ON
A GOOD PATH AT THE BORDER, UNDER
LEADERSHIP OF JOE BIDEN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WE WERE IN A VERY BAD SITUATION
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINITRATION.
BRIAN:  WELL THE GOOD NEWS FOR
HER IS MOST OF HER
CONSTITUENTS ARE HOMELESS
WITHOUT CABLE TV, KNOW THE TO
HEAR THAT SOUND BITE.
HOUSE MINORITY WHIP STEVE
SCALISE IS LEADING A DELEGATION
TO TEXAS FOR A FIRSTHAND LOOK TO
SEE IF NANCY PELOSI IS ACTUALLY
RIGHT, SO HOW THE BIDEN POLICIES
WORKING AT THE BORDER?
DOES SHE BELIEVE WHAT SHE JUST
SAID, CONGRESSMAN?
>> BRIAN, I DON’T KNOW HOW SHE
COULD EVEN SAY THAT WITH ANY
CREDIBILITY BECAUSE IF YOU TALK
TO ANYBODY ON THE GROUND, AND
TALKED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, IT IS BEYOND A
DISASTER.
WHAT THEY’VE DONE, NOT ONLY TO
THESE BORDER TOWNS, THE MAYORS
YOU HEAR THEM DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN, EXPRESSING OUTRAGE
OVER WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
CREATED.
JOE BIDEN CREATED THIS CRISIS,
BUT THE CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT
THAT’S GOING ON, IT’S NOT JUST
THE 20-PLUS DAY TRECKS THAT SOME
OF THESE YOUNG KIDS ARE TAKING
10 YEARS OLD IN MANY CASES OVER
A THIRD OF THE GIRLS ARE BEING
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OR  RAPED
ALONG THE JOURNEY AND THEN THEY
GET TO THE UNITED STATES AND YOU
SEE HOW THEY ARE BEING TREATED
NOT GIVEN PROPER FOOD AND
SHELTER BEING PUT NEXT TO
SOMEBODY SIX INCHES APART WITH
COVID.
ALL THIS IS GOING ON ON THE
BORDER YOU CAN SEE WHY VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS EITHER
DOESN’T WANT TO HAVE THIS DUMPED
IN OUR LAP BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
CREATED A MESS AND IS ASKING TO
MOP IT UP OR  ELSE SHE’S IN OVER
HER HEAD.
EITHER WAY, IT DOESN’T BODE WELL
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
OUR ALLIES AROUND THE WORLD
SURELY MEXICO HAD WORKED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO COME UP WITH
A GOOD PLAN TO REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY, BUT THINK ABOUT THIS TOO
, BRIAN.
YOU’VE GOT NOW AT LEAST SIX
PEOPLE ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST THAT HAVE BEEN CAUGHT.
THEY WON’T TELL US HOW MANY MORE
, NO DOUBT THERE’S MANY MORE
THAT HAVE COME ACROSS OUR BORDER
THIS ISN’T FROM CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA.
THIS IS FROM MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES, OTHER NATIONS WHERE
THEY HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST THAT
KNOW THERE’S A POOR SOUTHERN
BORDER AND IF YOU WANT TO COME
AND DO HARM IN AMERICA, IT’S
FREE REIGN.
IT’S OPEN SEASON, AND THIS IS
DANGEROUS FOR AMERICA, AND IT’S
EVEN MORE DANGEROUS TO THESE
KIDS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
POLICIES HAVE ENCOURAGED TO COME
ACROSS AND MAKE THE TECH
AND GET SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ALONG
THE WAY.
BRIAN:  WHEN YOU LOOK AT JOE
BIDEN’S APPROVAL RATINGS THEY
ARE PRETTY HIGH WHEN IT COMES TO
THE 1.9 TRILLION BECAUSE WE
DON’T HAVE THE MONEY AND NOW HE
WANTS 2.2 TRILLION PEOPLE GET
MONEY OUT OF THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION
IT’S IN ITS 40S.
I DON’T EVEN KNOW HOW FOUR OUT
OF 10 PEOPLE THINK THIS IS GOING
WELL.
YOU WANT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM LIKE GONZALEZ.
CONGRESSMAN, IS THIS SOMETHING
YOU CAN DO AT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL AND GET TO THE SECRETARY
MAYORKAS TO CLOSE THE GAPS IN
THE WALL, TO CUT A DEAL THAT
WORKS THAT WAS WORKING WITH
MEXICAN, TO DEAL WITH THE
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES BECAUSE
THIS IS REALLY CAUSING A PROBLEM
IN AMERICA, LET ALONE WHAT’S
GOING ON IN THESE FACILITIES.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING
PAPERS THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT
THROUGH LIKE A REVOLVING DOOR.
WHAT CAN YOU DO?
>> YEAH, AND LOOK THERE’S
BIPARTISAN INTEREST IN SOLVING
THIS , I THINK MORE AND MORE
MEMBERS RECOGNIZE THAT IT’S A
CRISIS.
YOU SEE HENRY CUELLAR, A
DEMOCRAT AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT
ARE EXPRESSING OUTRAGE WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S DECISION TO
CREATE THIS BUT YOU DON’T HAVE
TO REINVENT THE WHEEL.
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY WAS
WORKING
MAYBE JUST BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP
CAME UP WITH IT, JOE BIDEN CAN
CALL IT HIS OWN IDEA, AND THEN
REDO WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
THAT WAS WORKING WITH MEXICO.
MEXICO WAS NOT ONLY DEFENDING
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY WERE DEFENDING THEIR OWN
SOUTHERN BORDER AND PAYING FOR
IT AND IT WAS STOPPING THAT
FLOW OF MIGRANTS.
THEY CAN’T EVEN HANDLE THIS
SURGE THAT’S COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER AND THEY ARE TAKING
OVER MILITARY BASES, THE DALLAS
CONVENTION CENTER, ALL OF THEM
ARE GETTING OVERRUN, AND THE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND ARE
TELLING YOU THEY CAN’T CONTROL
IT.
ITS GOT TO STOP.
JOE BIDEN NEEDS REVERSE THIS
DEADLY DEVASTATING POLICY.
BRIAN:  YOU KNOW AS BAD AS
THINGS WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
NEVER TOLD BORDER PATROL DON’T
TALK TO PEOPLE.
HE NEVER TOLD THE OFFICIALS, THE
SHERIFFS NOT TO TALK TO
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BEEN HUSHED BORDER
PATROL, THE ONLY THING THEY CAN
DO IS ALLOW, TELL YOU THE STORY
AND THEN YOU COULD TELL IT HERE.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
YOUR IMPRESSIONS WHEN YOU’RE
DONE.